[Music]
let's hop back into ai for a moment so
you hang out with
the a lot of the smart cool kids
and very technical people who really
understand this stuff
when
they talk about
robots gone bad
or just the
plausible
scenarios that would be very bad
what are they like what are the two or
three things that they would see
as a
an event
or a development
that would sort of be the equivalent of
the trigger action plan right where it's
like oh this is life before and life
after what are these say two or three or
one to three scenarios
that
they've honed in on
from my perspective two extremely
worrying scenarios one is
that ai
systems get just much more powerful than
human systems and
they have goals that are misaligned with
human goals
and they
realize that
human beings are standing away of them
achieving their goals
and so they
take control
and perhaps that means they just like
wipe everyone out perhaps they don't
even need to so an analogy is often
given between
like the lies of homo sapiens from the
perspective of the chimpanzees
where
homo sapiens were just smarter
they were able to work together they
just had these advantages
and that just means the chimpanzees just
have very little say in how things go
over the long term basically no say
it's not that we made them extinct
although
in a sense they're kind of lucky we made
many you know in fact i think we made
most of large animals extinct due to the
rise of homo sapiens
but that could happen with ai as well we
could be
to the ai systems what chimpanzees are
to humans or perhaps it's actually more
extreme because once you've got air
systems that are smarter than you and
they're building air systems that are
smarter again maybe it's more like
we're like ants looking at humans
when we're looking at advanced ai
systems
so give me the second one and then i'm
going to come back to the first one with
just a sci-fi thought experiment for
sure and then the second one is like
okay even assume that we
do manage to align
air systems with human goals so we can
really get them to do whatever they want
nonetheless this could be a very scary
thing where
if you do think that ai systems could
lead to much faster rates of
technological progress
for in particular by you know automating
technological discovery including the
creation of better ai systems see like
we've got ai writing the code that
builds the next generation of ai that
then writes even better code to build
the next generation of ai things could
happen like very quickly
well
even if you manage to
have ai systems do exactly what you want
them to do
well that could concentrate power in
you know a very small number of hands
could be a
single country could be a company it
could be like an individual within a
single country who wants to instill a
dictatorship
and then once you've got that power
with it and it's kind of similar to what
happened during the industrial
revolution and earlier so
you have got more and more powerful
technology over that period and what did
it do it used it to
you know colonize and subjugate a very
large faction of the world
in the same way it could happen but even
faster that a small group get such power
and use it to
essentially take over the world and then
once it's in power well once you've got
ai systems
i think you're able to have
indefinite social control in a way
that's like very worrying and this is
value lock-in again
where at the limit imagine you're kind
of the dictator of a totalitarian state
like 1984 or the handmaid's tale or
something
and that's a global totalitarian state
and you really want your ideology
to persist forever
well you can pass that ideology on to
this ai successor it just says like yep
you go all the world now and the ai has
no need to die it's
like software it can replicate itself
indefinitely so
unlike dictators
who will die off eventually causing a
certain amount of change to occur well
this is not true for the ai could
replicate itself indefinitely and it
could be like in every area of society
and so then when you've got that it's
like why would we expect moral change
after that point and it's like
kind of hard to see
so in general i think there can be these
states where you get into a particular
state of the world and you just kind of
can't get out of it again
and this kind of orwellian perpetual
like totalitarianism is actually one of
the things i really worry about
you